there is both a talent and a skills gap
in the workforce this is driven by a
number of factors including demands for
speed innovation and flexibility in
fast-paced environments combined with a
growing deficit in technical proficiency
recent events have only fueled to this
fire further and organizations are
looking for strategies to reduce their
talent gaps now more than ever
so how do organizations solve for this
i'm stephanie and in this video we'll
discuss why digital upskilling your
workforce with appsheet is one of the
most impactful decisions you can make to
improve resiliency let's get started
[Music]
no matter the industry or job to be done
the demand for digital skills has
increased dramatically
there is an expectation to work with
technology in nearly every component of
work in part because it is no longer
siloed to a singular function
daily duties for a variety of jobs
include data analysis process
improvement and automation to name a few
with digital upskilling you can empower
your workforce to problem solve in a new
way
not every person on your team needs to
be a data or development expert but they
can leverage democratized technology to
address their fundamental line of
business needs
so whether you're an operator a
marketing professional or even an i.t
specialist
you will find value in developing custom
solutions that make your work even
easier
you just need the right platform
that's why we built appsheet a platform
that empowers anyone regardless of your
role in the organization to build custom
applications and automations with it
governance and security in mind
and since no coding is required to be
successful with the platform it's the
perfect jumping off point for digital
upskilling
few organizations have the time for the
traditional development cycles what is
needed is a problem-solving mentality
secure data and speed
with appsheet the platform's
intelligence does the heavy lifting
built-in machine learning ingests
selected data from the approved source
the intention of that data is then
analyzed producing a suggested
application or automation prototype in a
matter of moments
for example data with dates may produce
a calendar in your application to help
manage a series of projects your data
contains
furthermore non-technical workers can
enhance the custom applications or
automations they're building with the
platform's natural language capabilities
you don't need to learn how to code or
invest in additional development talent
to do this you simply need to learn how
to articulate the problem you're trying
to solve for with the applications and
automations you wish to build
time and talent are critical to the
success of any organization and we've
learned that the traditional siloed ways
of working aren't as effective as they
once were
with an innovative no code platform like
appsheet organizations are able to not
only upskill their workforce to address
talent and skill gaps but they have the
confidence that they're investing in a
more digitally resilient and engaged
workforce
ready to start your no code journey
click the link below
[Music]